hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to seven days to die
with me and Wade hey guys hi Wade mark
gonna stir crazy while we're here huh
we've been slinging Hana we've been long
in our slings if you know what I mean
this sounds like a dr. Seuss rhyme gone
horribly bad if you know what I mean I
would not sling your slung to here I
would not sling it anywhere I wouldn't
swing it with a rope I wouldn't sling it
with the Pope
I wouldn't sling it on the dope I
wouldn't sling it here or there
oh no I already did that one I we are
not dr. Seuss and in honor of dr. Suzan
memory in the childhood memories of
everyone we're gonna keep going
I would not sling it with her pull it
with her I would not sling it with a dog
I would not sling it all day long and
what are you doing dear dear oh the deer
has breached our perimeter somehow dear
no oh god I didn't even know there was
one there poor dear we've killed more
animals with our defenses over here we
haven't killed a single zombie can I say
this hi dear
Hey on oh it got away
whew it's gonna be okay
it's gonna live to see another day maybe
it's gonna Swan oh dear dear dear you
all the way no there are no zombies but
there's so many summer sized woodland
creatures movie Bambi really starts oh
my god don't even say that this is
Abbott just deer and rabbits where are
the zombies this is the hardest
difficulty this is hard to watch all
these suicide I know they're sooo sad oh
okay do you see any more coming up not
yeah I'm sure they'll be playing I don't
know how there's still more alive how do
they keep spawning and seriously what I
hear just are are there like no zombies
in the north
there should be yeah there should be
maybe the four torches I put down there
keeping them at bay
or maybe somehow I accidentally slipped
it to the easiest difficulty and
disabled zombies have we seen a single
zombie since we started
uh yeah yeah and the tech no we didn't
go through the town no that was before
when we didn't split have we seen a
single zombie remember did I mess up
with the game hey should we go explore
it I don't think we should go anywhere
what hang on a second it's that mess you
say the head how no I'm not gonna buy
Wow God not again
oh god not again baby baby out of love
for the woodland creatures that we are
destroying we should get out of here
Oh God ah they keep damn it
I keep having it so bad there's so many
bodies like let's leave we gotta leave
get out this way I think yeah
Oh God oh we don't know no just climb up
on the music box and get out that way
just keep walking out you'll fall yeah
you'll fall Oh didn't hurt that bad
it's stung nah oh god it's right here
oh so sad I'm gonna skin it alive and
eat its meat but with love are you how
that noise was
yeah what do you think it was I don't
know yeah you don't want to know baby I
look at a flashlight I think somehow
zombies bonds got turned off I don't
know maybe I do that I don't know I
don't know if you can't oh let's go the
other way there's more buildings over
there
okay maybe there'll be some else I can't
if I if I actually did like mess up I
greatly apologize
and the only thing we ever killed was
was animals I think the whole is mean
helpless little animal I don't know
so many dead rabbits and deer it was the
hardest difficulty I have to say cuz
like the number of spawns and the items
were gone other than that I really don't
know I'm just gonna eat my corn so where
are we going now wait a baby I don't
know where the buildings that you're
leading us to look on your map stupid I
thought you were leading us there look
on your map you'll know where we're
going peer to the left on this dirt path
yeah no yeah all right let's see that
first well there are more landmines this
game why'd you say would you save me you
heard me
no actually I didn't would you say to me
are you scared of the zombies that don't
exist
apparently not I mean this corn it's not
doing anything why am I not getting any
nutrition from this place you to fix it
with water and make corn bread
heyno corn bread yeah I got corn seeds a
lot of them why would you do that my eat
the corn seeds okay I can't eat the corn
what is this building I don't know it
looks big I got a hope in a pickaxe I
told you they'd be hoes haha
there is one ho you did not find hosszú
here here with your sling yeah that I've
been swinging all over oh is that where
the term swinging comes from is it no I
don't think that's even is it a term I'm
slinging my sling around town walking
fast moving fast
oh god someone make that into a remix
there's a lamp here there's nothing in
here there are no zombies on this map I
have to say that right now there are no
zombies on this map what's going to
seven days to live well good job Wade
there's nothing to see here babe the
game I mean do not have some
the one responsible can I just say we've
never played this game with everything
going right
ergo is it really my fault no it's
pretty much fate all right pick up I
don't know where are you I'm serious
hey Zoe you want to play rocket tag
rocket no yeah I think you want to play
rocket tag and guess who's it Oh God
better run boy oh I didn't reload hang
on run little run floor ok
whoosh aah did I get you Delta we're yet
oh yeah boo me
we have boobs well yeah baby
oh we're lovin to go on the map maybe
you should run wait I got you a buggy Oh
missed you by that much uh no no no no
no no no no that's not fair we're
re-enacting the scene from what shining
except this time it's called the
slinging wait I've only got one rocket
left what so worse that could happen
damn it did I almost get you yeah here's
Mark II where yucky Oh No there's a
corny way to die yeah here's all your
corn that you left over didn't you have
any land mines or did you place them all
I place them all damn it now how shall I
die being frozen in this wasteland of
you could run back to the to the dead I
could run into your ass no that won't do
I don't know that's not what I meant
what I meant was no good you drunk what
I could run into your ass
No god damn it I keep doing it again
yeah you need to stop hey I'm gonna go
do something with my life some don't
know what though
am I supposed to wait at spawn for you
panel
I'll do whatever you want to do I'm
running back to the farm do a little
dance do a little dance for the camera
so everybody at home can see how good of
a dancer you are
oh that's amazing how do you move like
that oh no were you born with such
rhythm there's no dancing oh I'm still
dancing is Molly there she's looking at
you judging Leigh nerf is not here okay
good cuz that would be awfully
embarrassing if anyone could see this
okay here you my headphones fellow good
great I wasn't talking good I'm so dizzy
now I'm about to be melodramatic I'm
about to be melodramatic so give me give
me a moment of prior time for my best
Shakespeare Oh what doth guilt lies in
my heart it is burns with more intensity
than a thousand suns I have killed my
own brother of another mother and he is
now dead I cannot live with my shame
ergo I will blow myself the [ __ ] up
goodbye cruel world like the rest and
goodbye audience this was a waste of
yours and my time where are you where
are you ah damn it your although ok
whatever [ __ ]
sorry guys I [ __ ] up are you
struggling Shakespeare no oh my
apologies mine viewers audience tefik I
[ __ ] up that's it
so thank you all so much for watching
thank ya we're ending it on that yeah we
are so see you in the next one not of
this game
I'm gonna throw up